hey guys I'm Brent Rose writer and
fleshy projectile today we're talking
about hoverboards no not these fake-ass
bullsh
no hovering fire bursting wheel having
wheelie boards we're talking about
honest-to-goodness hovering hoverboards
so we're here at arcs pax in Los Gatos
California we're going to check out the
brand new Hendo hoverboard - my name is
Shawna I'm one of the engineers here at
arc specs we do magnetic field
architecture this is the original
hoverboard that we built back in October
of 2014
this is like the board that Tony Hawk
rode this is the board Tony Hawk came in
took it on the ramp you want to take it
for a spin I do the only person who
hasn't won a helmet is Tony Hawk yeah I
am NOT talking yeah oh this is so cool
oh yeah I'm hovering mom I push up you
and what is the remote control do it
makes you go flying on yeah okay that's
the original as you hear it's a little
loud that was one of the things we
strive to improve at our 2.0 obviously
what we're standing on here is not your
standard concrete Street we're on copper
yeah yes we are standing on copper
there's a magnetic field that's
generated in the engine it's a dynamic
magnetic field which means it's changing
and when you put that in proximity with
an electrically conductive material
creates an electric circuit and that
electric circuit in turn creates a
secondary magnetic field and those two
repel each other and that's what creates
the lift really heavy
it is heavy it's very conductive
so this is the 2.0 yes as you can see
it's definitely a different form factor
than the original board we had some
input from Tony Hawk actually about
staying with the skateboard deck the
classic look that people kind of
familiar and comfortable with underneath
here we've got our battery pack much
larger and more energy-dense that we
have longer runtime for engines that's
the same but there are slightly
different configurations so they are a
little bit more powerful with a little
more lift from them a little bit more
efficient as well cool this one you can
just push the button and lifts off all
by itself and is it sort of more
maneuverable at this point yes is that
these skateboard shops and they're on
either end as you rock your weight back
and forth on this deck these engines are
going to move and they're going to tilt
a little bit allows you to give a little
bit of input so I can just basically
shred the gnar you can try this noise
not going to shred itself oh yeah it's
way quieter alright oh yeah I can't
really you know steer or control myself
but definitely more stable than the
original I know let me play
me
you
oh yeah this is so fun yeah hands hard
pretty well for stealing but I feel like
we can come up with something better
not really doing much
how about we add some closed-loop
control to this problem this is our
white box plus it's sort of a generic
embodiment of our technology for engines
in the bottom there's a microcontroller
inside so we're actually redirecting the
magnetic fields the engines actually
pivoting in this place yeah the engines
are actually activating so that magnetic
field orientation to the surface here is
changing is that something that maybe
you guys are thinking about for like the
Hendo 3.0 absolutely we can take this up
to something that's ever would size
something that's more industrial a
Hyperloop pod perhaps perhaps we'll see
just say oh it's so cute feel springy
I'm not pushing too hard my dad yeah
small touches small presses yeah this
actually feels a lot like just flying
like a phantom type drone
yeah good boy so this is just a single
engine same as the ones in the white box
and it's just to allow you to get a
sense of what that one engine is
actually doing good oh yeah Wow
it probably looks like I'm muscling it
right now with my hand but it's actually
just the rotation of my wrist
it's very Ouija board ish can you use
these things for like contact dead
roboticists and cells we should try that
10 people actually bought these on
Kickstarter yeah yeah some very lucky
kid out there is like building their own
copper skate park in their backyard
right now so what did we learn here
today well first of all hoverboards are
awesome yeah I couldn't carve like I
would if I were on a snowboard but we
can already see how that sort of thing
is possible just by tilting the little
engine and that small adjustment was
able to provide more control and more
power than that stupid leaf blower which
was an abject failure and that brings up
an interesting point
most of the Hyperloop designs we've seen
so far require forced air moving a pod
through a tunnel according to Greg
Henderson
ARC's packs a CEO pound-for-pound their
magnetic system requires just 1/4 the
amount of power as a fan based system
for propulsion if you're looking at a
system as big as a Hyperloop that would
be a huge amount of savings it's
definitely something that should be
investigated what do you think of all
this technology let us know in the
comments below subscribe to Wired if you
haven't already with all that being said
there's really only one thing left to do